this is a production of Cornell
University
awesome cool okay well today I'm going
to be sharing the work of a whole host
of people uh shown here on the screen
but first I would like to introduce us
to the maze classical Gene iodine
Japonica one now this chain causes the
leaf variegation striping that you see
here it was cloned in 1992 and it's
shown here having five exons now if I
want to study this Gene today I would go
to a remains reference genome browser
where I would promptly see that our V5
annotation version only has three exons
when I was expecting to see five
so the question is what causes this
discrepancy and while the answer is that
Gene model annotation is really really
hard and this is due both to
computational errors and biological
noise
so if we start by thinking of just the
gene models that we know are being
translated into proteins we're going to
run into problems right off the bat from
alternative splicing
if we expand out and we start looking at
the gene models they're being
transcribed into mRNA here we start
seeing more problems due to biological
noise so things like pre-spliced mrnas
fractionation and duplication
and finally if we start looking at all
annotated Gene models here's where we
start to run into more of our
bioinformatic type errors so these are
just prediction errors from our software
especially in mace te related chaos in
the genome as well as read mapping
errors
now if we start shifting our Focus From
The genome to the protein itself we know
that the cell spends most of its energy
on protein so about 99 of that ATP is
going towards generating proteins and so
it makes sense that selection is going
to be focusing on what is translated and
we might be able to find those good Gene
models now essentially by looking at
which ones are evolutionarily
constrained now there's two different
approaches that we could take here one
is looking at proteins and the other is
looking at more the conservation of our
axons
so if we start by looking at proteins we
know that functional proteins have
strong evolutionary conservation both in
its structure and folds that persist
across all of life this is really
apparent because of alpha fold 2 as well
as protrans
and when we think of protrans in this
example we have found that functional
proteins actually have a grammar that is
consistent and learnable across all of
life
so what protrans has done here is
they've taken over 2 billion proteins
across life they have fed them into a
Transformer language model and they
basically get out this representation of
a protein that is a numerical embedding
into 1024 space
and Jing Jing in our lab has been able
to develop a protein model that
accurately predicts if there's a
functionally conserved protein in Maize
and so what she's done here is she's
taken all b73 transcripts she has run
them through protrans and got in this
embedding Matrix and then train an XG
boost model
and now this model is trained both on
the Nam Gene classifications so core
shared across all 26 landlines versus
non-cores shared between 1 and 23 but
she also went one step further and she
trained on simulated intron retention as
well as Exxon locks
which really added to the robustness of
this training set and as you can see by
her model uh PR and rock curves here the
AUC is about 0.95 so that means that
she's having very very high precision
and accuracy here with her
classifications
so we know that there's this for the
gene models that are translated into
proteins there's this grammar that is
conserved across all of life we want to
think about this uh one step up we into
the gene models that are transcribed
into mRNA we can assume that there is
this grammar conserved across all the
grasses
now how this looks is that correct exons
we expect are going to have evolutionary
support so say we have three different
transcripts here for the same gene if we
align them to four different species we
can see that this third transcript is
the one with the most support
how this looks in maze is we can expand
out into the anthropaganie which is the
encompassing tribe and it captures about
a billion years of evolution
and so as part of the NSF panan Grant
Taylor Aubuchon Elder at the danforce
center has gone out and collected over
800 of these antagonia species and a
huge collaborative effort by everyone
shown here
and we've now assembled over 450 of
these antragonia genomes both from short
and long rates Sovereign from the
Hufford Lab at Iowa State did all the
long read assemblies and I've done all
the short read assemblies
and as you can see here we've been able
to largely capture our Gene space
and so for the remainder of this talk
I'm going to be focusing in only on 33
of our long reads and 58 of our short
read assemblies
so this pipeline real Gene in addition
to looking at proteins you can use
Evolution to predict if a transcript is
under selection for a functional protein
using this exact method I just
highlighted before we have our three
different transcripts we now can take
these antropagonia assemblies align them
to those transcripts and see that the
third one has the most support
and so how this looks is Zach and
Brandon in our lab developed a pipeline
to generate a series of multiple
sequence alignments to every single maze
transcript so we have 72 000 of these
multiple sequence alignments
and then Shanghai was able to
find out that the evolutionary
constraint of key molecular Junctions
are in fact predictable by training four
separate models and so what he did here
just by looking at the Junctions as he
pulled out these different summary
statistics for the different types of
Junctions so these were our translation
start site our splicing donor site are
splicing acceptor site and then our
translation stop site he trained this
again on her name core and not core
designation but took it one step further
and simulated some splice sight
shuffling so we have another estimation
of Errors when it comes to what could be
a bad annotation
and then I was able to take those models
that Shanghai generated and combine them
in addition to some more Exxon and
intron summary statistics and put them
into a lstm machine learning model now
if you're not familiar with lstms you
can think of them as kind of like a
hidden Markov model of the machine
learning world so again these are
trained to generate an Exon quality
score and predict whether or not we have
functionally conserved axons
and now our two very different
approaches within real Gene both show
high levels of precision and accuracy
you'll see our protein and our
exon-based models both have aucs of
around 0.95
and so why this is exciting Is that real
Gene actually allows us to find the real
genes in the sense that we can start to
tailor things when it's the axon versus
the protein-based model but for the rest
of today I'm just going to be talking
about the average of our axon and
protein models here
so when we look at how real Gene
performs with our Nam classifications
you'll see that only the core and near
core genes are largely being predicted
as functional so we're at 89 of our core
while our dispensable and private chains
are only on about eight and four percent
now I want to highlight these eight and
four percent of genes could actually be
sources of adaptation that we could go
and look at and potentially help future
breeding programs
now I want to draw your attention next
to this uh Pink area on the screen these
are our classical genes and so 99 of
them are functional what's one of the
ones that's not well it brings us right
back to our iodine chaponica and when we
look at the real Gene classification it
is predicted as non-functional which
being that the Clone Gene has five exons
it looks like real Gene was correct and
sure enough if you look back at previous
annotation versions both version 4 and
version 3 of b73
have the correct number of axons here
and it's only in version 5 that we see
this loss of exons
at this point you might be wondering
okay you trained on the core or non-core
set it makes sense you see this
beautiful distribution what about
against Real data well when we compare
it to the maze expression Atlas we find
that most genes that are expressed above
Baseline levels are predicted to be
functional or about 78 meat are 0.5
threshold
and what's even more exciting is that
genes that are found in the podium are
largely predicted to be functional that
right now at our 0.5 threshold we're at
93 percent are predicted by real Gene to
be functional and we think that those
remaining seven percent are in fact real
genes but just bad annotations
and so to bring this back full circle I
really want to highlight and emphasize
that real Gene is going to be a
community resource across species not
just Maize and it's a pipeline for
evaluating Gene models so people will be
able to take Gene model transcripts
feed them into a web server and then get
an output of real Gene scores
additionally for all the maze people in
the room we already have scores
generated for b73 V5 and we are
currently in the process of generating
them for the rest of NAMM and all prior
b73 versions to follow
and finally I just really want to
emphasize again that a real Gene is
going to allow us to determine the most
evolutionarily supported Gene models to
help out our future research especially
in the case for say you have multiple
alternative transcripts for a single
Gene and you're trying to figure out
which one is the best one that we want
to use
and so at this point there's a whole
host of people that I need to thank I
also would like to thank my funding
sources uh give a shout out to K mcneary
for Designing our logo and I'm more than
happy to take any questions
yeah yeah so the the question for those
of you online is how useful will real
team be outside of the Andrew paganie
and the answer is it will be useful
because we're setting up this entire
pipeline so that if you have other
species outside of the Andrew paganie uh
you can follow it and add in your own
assemblies and it'll still take it
through the entire training process to
the end so it's basically this framework
of
how you can compare it to say multiple
other closely related species as you can
see short reads do work and you can
follow it from there
yeah so it's a whole framework that
people will be able to use not just in
the Andrew paganie
uh the TVD it's in progress right now
um come talk to us if you're there's a
time crunch and we can help you
yeah so uh Jeff's question was what do
you need in order to do this how many
genomes
that actually is a question that we are
working on asking I mean right now we
have you know 90 genomes that we threw
in there
um
I am hoping to address this question of
how few genomes and how evolutionarily
distant do they need to be in order to
have that support I will say if you want
to follow the protein model you can do
that without any other genomes if you're
more interested in the exxon-based model
which is really uh highlighting kind of
the conservation of key Junctions and
other features you know I would probably
want at least 10 other uh just throwing
a number out
um different genomes but they can be
short read
basically all we need to be able to do
is align your transcript of interest to
those other genomes and then it can be
fed through the pipeline so they don't
need to be annotated
yeah so the dispensable and private
genes uh so
those are a classification
within uh the maze NAMM uh population so
the founders are 26 different lines a
private Gene is a gene that was found in
only one of those 26 lines well just a
dispensable Gene was found anywhere
between 2 and 23 of those lines
uh so they were basically specifically
found only in that line
um
most of them are looking like they're
not real genes uh they but as you can
see here about four percent look to be
functional and that again could be a
specific you know novel source of
adaptation you could look at
that more newly useful
yeah that's a great question so Anna
just asked how do we balance between
evolutionary conservation and a protein
that's more newly evolved my answer to
this has been actually uh the difference
in how you weigh the protein model
versus the uh Exon model so that Exxon
model is going to weigh much more
heavily how conserved something is
versus the protein model it's basically
being trained on doesn't have a
particular uh it's like are the
structures and the folds that kind of
occur with that from you know basically
this representation from protrans are
those basically characteristic of a
protein so I would look more on that
side if you're thinking you have a newer
more novel protein
any other questions
awesome well thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu